i think it's become clearer that
fairness is overrated
the idea that we should always give two
sides equal weight
and merit does not reflect the world we
find ourselves in
nbc now putting those words into
practice the network under fire for
deceptively editing
the 9-1-1 call that preceded a fatal
police shooting
of a teenage girl in ohio police body
cam video shows a columbus officer
shooting 16-year-old
makia bryant as she was lunging with a
knife at another woman but the part of
the 9-1-1 call
that nbc aired left out the part
about the attempted stabbing officer
nicholas reardon who joined the force
in december of 2019 was responding to a
9-1-1
call we need a police officer here now
and here's the actual 9-1-1 call
these girl girls over here trying to
fight us trying to stop us trying to put
our hands on our grandma getting
we need a police officer here now
joining me now molly hemingway senior
editor at the federalist and joe koncha
the hill media opinion columnist
both are fox news contributors joe and
molly thanks so much for taking the time
to join me tonight
great to be here with ben so i i have to
ask for your reactions
to this situation with nbc it seems to
me that so many
of our corporate media entities out
there
are interested in fomenting racial rage
as opposed to actually depicting the
true
story about these different events that
happen that certainly are concerning
but are not depictions of race-based
violence on the part of the cops
against various people in america molly
what are your thoughts on this
so much of the privilege that media
figures have had has been built on this
idea
that they that they take and synthesize
information and they
provide context and help provide a
shared set of facts for the american
people
that's not what they're doing anymore
they have moved into straight up
propaganda
in this case it does seem that they are
desiring to foment racial division
because that aligns with the political
goals of their favorite party on the
left
but they do it in so many ways i think
people need to stop being surprised when
they see it happening because it happens
with everything whether it's
the russia collusion hoax or the
kavanaugh hoax or the covington hoax
or deceptively editing governor ron
desantis's answer on
vaccine distribution it's just what they
do as a matter of course
and this week we've seen it that they
will even do it when it's something as
fraught as racial division
joe i think that this is a situation
that unfortunately doesn't seem like it
has any real solution
is there a way to get these media
entities to start behaving more
responsibly
and not you know trying to push this
toxic racist approach to every frame of
every story
then they got to be called out but they
got to be called out by their own
i want to see the op-eds in the new york
times in the washington post
by cnn people they don't expect to
criticize them nbc
in this case because that's the only way
you're really going to get their
attention
you mentioned about how the media is
serving to divide the country further oh
yeah gallup had a poll last year
83 percent of americans believe that the
media bears the blame for division
in this country think about that for a
second in 1976
media had a 72 percent approval rating
in the cronkite era
so today nbc had to put out a statement
to apologize
for not issuing that full 9-1-1 call
because that's the real context when you
hear
a girl pleading she's trying to stab us
or when they actually edited out
the knife in the hand of the attacker in
the original report
we should have seen apologies we should
have seen retractions we saw
nothing all we saw was punditry on
places like msnbc which seemed to
actually justify knife fights uh going
on
between kids this was a one-way knife
fight a and b there was actually a 13
year old girl in cincinnati that was
stabbed to death
by another 13 year old this isn't
playtime now
and this is a very serious situation
that we have here in terms of
police and race and tensions are high
nbc had to get it right they got it
wrong it's
molly's point they didn't get it wrong
because they made a mistake they got it
wrong because they were trying to push a
narrative a dangerous one that could end
up getting people killed that you
mentioned that uh commentary on cnn and
msnbc
let's run that and get some reaction
what if it were your daughter what if it
were your child
what if it were a member of your family
your neighbor uh
in a uh essentially a teenage fight a
schoolyard fight
i remember fights in even high school or
even younger than that where a kid
brought a pen knife or something to
school and
teachers were able to defuse that and
they'd have guns
molly i listened to this and it seems so
deeply
unserious but also it's gaslighting it's
trying to make you believe
something that is at odds with
everything that you see in front of you
isn't it
there's no comparison between a backyard
tussle
or getting getting down with someone in
a schoolyard
and an attempted murder and everyone
should be able to look at this situation
and have thoughtful commentary about how
awful it is that there even is a
situation where this
one girl is attacking another girl where
there are adults involved where a police
officer has to make that kind of
decision
but to just make up ridiculous things
like acting like it's normal
for two teenagers to try to kill each
other that's not normal and if it is
normal
you know there's something wrong with
that as well joe
one more thing i wanted to bring up to
you this
interesting story from the washington
examiner about politico
sending an email sending a letter to
their own
writers saying essentially that they
cannot use the term
crisis when describing the border
despite the fact that the president
himself has actually
used this word to me this seems like
a classic example of the media trying to
reframe a story that they don't like
in ways that they would prefer it to
exist this
type of thing i'm sure goes on behind
the scenes
but knowing that it's going on at a
major publication like politico
shouldn't there be a response from
readers that basically says
you know aren't you trying to gaslight
us aren't you trying to
reflect a certain perspective that you
would like to exist as opposed to the
reality
oh ben i wouldn't even use crisis either
i agree with politico it's a catastrophe
going on at the border right now when
you see facilities at 17 times
their capacity during a pandemic when
you see
reports of young girls possibly being
sexually abused
in these facilities when you see 20 000
unaccompanied migrant children
now in u.s custody and one facility in
houston having to be closed because it
was so dangerous
uh yeah i think crisis definitely
applies catastrophe does and for
politico to try to downplay this
i'd like to see the justification around
that what words should we use here
politico because
this is something that obviously is very
problematic probably the biggest issue
facing the bind administration
and they're providing cover by playing
word games when it's not a game down the
board it's a very very serious situation
ben
molly hemingway joe koncha what you do
when it comes to media criticism is one
of the most important things that we
have in terms of our conversation in
this country thank you for joining me
tonight
thank you appreciate it